[Music]
all right let's go to
kyle in los angeles kyle respect my
authority what's up dude how we doing
hey i'm doing great i just got to talk
to kelly daniel and now dr john deloney
today and it's not even 7 30 a.m so i'm
having a great day already
hey listen i got to talk to kelly this
morning and my day got better too so
i absolutely know what you're
experiencing trust me
after a few minutes with me we will
bring you back down to
just regular so what's up man
so my question was how do you create and
nurture
a ride or die group of friends who hold
you accountable
my wife that's a good question man
thank you and my wife and i have been
listening to your show since the first
episode
i we hear you and dave talk about that
all the time
yeah um so i feel like i'm kind of 80
there like i have plenty of friends who
i talk to frequently
sometimes about tough things but it just
feels like i'm like just a little bit
away from really having
kind of my picture of a group who might
hold me accountable and call me out
when i'm violating my values and i want
to be that kind of friend for other
people
and i guess i'm just not sure how to get
that last step or if i'm overthinking
this
or you know what i can do
man yeah so hey um
talking to your phone okay but i'm gonna
i'm gonna recap it
and let me know if i'm right on so
you want to know how to create ride or
dive friends and you've heard me talking
about and
by the way big shout out to you and your
wife for being
the first two or three listeners that
hung on for the first 100 or so episodes
that's pretty rad
um but i talk a lot about
having a good crew that is with you that
will hold you accountable that will
laugh with you that will cry with you
pick you up when things when you fall
down and so you're wondering how to
cultivate that and you've got a group of
friends that you think are 80 percent
there but they just don't feel like they
got that last 20
what do you think that last 20 is what
does that feel like to you
yeah so i think to me it's like
if they see me you know they they can
speak into my life like if they see me
doing something that might be against my
values or their values if they
kind of feel empowered to speak up and
that they
will do that or hold me accountable do
they do that now
i don't think so okay have you ever
given them permission to do that
or have you ever said hey call me out on
this
no i i don't think i have
ta-da hey so
um whenever i talk about
ride or die guys here's in men and women
i got both in my life
usually it comes from two places number
one mutually shared experiences
where we have been through crap together
co-workers and all of a sudden the boss
quits or fires a bunch of people or
suddenly passes away or there's a car
wreck and
everybody's gotta just rise to that
occasion so you can't really plan those
things they happen
and then you look around and the smoke
clears and you realize i got a
group that's walking alongside me in
this deal the other
so you got mutually shared experiences
that's why a lot of people
stay connected to their childhood
friends forever or they stay really
connected their college friends because
everybody got picked up and from their
homes everyone they knew and loved or
everyone they hated it whatever and they
got dropped in a box in a dorm they all
shared a bathroom together
and you just got to figure it out right
or that's why military bodies stay
together for years and years and years
or police officers or firemen ems they
have these shared experiences man and it
is
like they've literally had to ride or
die together
and so shared experience is one
those get harder as you get older right
that's why you end up being just friends
with
like little league dads or
you know you sit by the same people in a
lawn chair next to a soccer game you
become friends with them that becomes
your shared experience which is
really a watered down watching fifth
graders run around on a soccer field as
a water dad it's not really a shared
experience but it kind of is right
um the other one is intentionality
i am choosing to because of my season of
life to develop a set of friends
and i'm gonna intentionally go first and
put some things out there
so here's a couple of things the way i
would um
when i talk about those here's some guys
in my life here's some ways that's
happened
i got a group of guys that we used to
hang out with when i was at one
university
several universities ago a couple of
those guys are still i talk to you on a
weekly basis if not more frequent um
i remember i just moved to town and they
invited me and we were hanging out doing
something and i made some crack my wife
had to move six months later she was
finishing her dissertation she had to
move six months later
and so i was by myself in this new town
alone and i made some
joke about um total joke about
um dating while i waited for her to come
there's some just stupid pop off
whatever and my buddy who's one of my
best buddies now
looked at me and said hey we don't know
you that well you don't know us so just
so we were clear
if you ever cheat on your wife you
better hope to god she finds you before
we do
and they all just smiled at me and i
remember going
whoa okay you know what i mean it and so
what what i'm telling you
it was a highly intentional these were
friends these were guys being silly they
knew i was kidding
i was i mean good god i was totally
kidding but
just in case there was any any thing
that wasn't clear
here's where we stand on that does that
make sense
and so there was it was highly
intentional and then we ended up having
some shared experiences
and we were intentional about meeting
every week we were intentional about
being around each other's kids we were
intentional about doing fun things once
a month you know we all watched the
fights together whatever
and then we had shared experiences on
the back of that eventually somebody's
house catches on fire eventually
somebody needs help
doing something in their yard so we had
these shared experiences together
another one is me and some of my oldest
friends in the world
we've all been married for a long time
and we all have we all know me and
and john and todd we all know man if
if y'alls ever get crossways with your
wives i don't care who's at fault or why
she gets to stay with us and so everyone
knows that's kind of the rule
even if my wife cheated on me and
she i'm she would be okay at their house
them them letting me know me letting
them know i'm not gonna go to war i'm
not gonna pick sides here
because i love both of you and we'll
walk alongside you guys and whatever
happens and so
it becomes this outspoken thing
we were intentional about saying hey
here's what our values are also
i will tell them hey i'm starting a new
workout program and they are
love to catch me grabbing a donut in the
middle of a workout program they love it
right and they
oh man they will call me out and vice
versa
i'm thinking about losing weight you're
clearly not because you just ordered
double barbecue whatever that's that's
part of
being friends and part of being
connected there but it comes with
intentionality
and so i'd ask you man go first
go first does that make you nervous or
uncomfortable to do that kyle
it makes me a little bit nervous but i
think not too nervous to actually do it
okay i would love to see if you got some
friends that you think are 80
there that to me is one million percent
worth
worth the risk what do you got to lose
because hey if they're not those guys
quit wasting your time man waste your
time
if they are call them together and say
hey i'm gonna start working on these two
things in my life
whatever it is i'm gonna start lifting
weights i'm gonna start i'm gonna start
going on date nights with my wife i
wanna be a better husband whatever you
wanna do
start pick pick a couple of things and
then call them together and say
i want you all to call me out on this
stuff i trust you guys
i need some accountability i don't trust
myself all the time
i want you all to set up some to help me
with my boundaries
my gut tells me dude they will be all in
and you could tell them y'all can make
fun of me
you can laugh at me you can email me
text me oh
give them the boundaries and then ask is
there anything i can help you guys with
and they may say no you weirdo this
whole thing is weird why are you
inviting us into this ugh gross let's
just play
pokemon or whatever you guys are doing
and let's just go back to fortnite and
quit speaking
um my gut tells me they're gonna be
jazzed
for real does that sound cool
yes i think i i think they will be happy
actually
okay so here's here's the plan kyle i
want you to do this i want you to
don't be all weird and dramatic about it
don't send them like notes
and say hey guy friends um this weekend
i want to have a talk about our values
and accountability don't do that
because that'd make you weird but you
all go out go watch the fights this
weekend or y'all go hey
i don't know what y'all do like i'm just
dragging you into my world
um you all get together and go do
something and then say hey listen here's
two things i'm gonna work on
do that i want you to write me back and
let me know how that conversation goes
if i if i totally just blew it for you
um then i will commiserate with you and
i will announce to
all 106 listeners that i screwed up
um my gut tells me they're going to be
all in and they're going to be jazzed
about it and then you're going to have
to be able to accept the accountability
when they start making fun of your
eating choices
or your workout choices or how you're
not being as good a husband as you
probably should be
and so on and so on and so on and so on
invite your wife to do the same thing
in a relationship if you're ever stuck
marriage
parenting friendship go first
go first what are you waiting for what
are you waiting for go first you're
going to find out that that
those relationships weren't with what
you thought or
you're going to be the first person to
extend the hand and start healing that
thing
but go first got nothing to lose man you
got nothing to lose and everything in
the game
awesome question kyle thank you so much
and thanks for letting me talk about my
two two or three four guys i love kyle i
mean uh
kevin and michael and john and todd i
love it man it's awesome